This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the U.S. Air Force.
The best way to get over your fear of spiders
is to pick up a spider.
YEAH, THIS WILL GO FINE.
Self-preservation instinct exists in every
type of life form, even single-celled organisms.
As our brains advance we began to grasp logic
and reason, and understand complex emotions
like sympathy, but the limbic system, which
controls fear, is still deep in there.
Fear is a powerful thing and overcoming it
can be even more difficult.
The amygdala is ready to hit the panic button
in a second, and it's always there... deep
in your brain...
Evolution has built us to avoid fear, and
it's so strong people who are paralyzed by
trauma may change their entire social structure
to avoid triggering their amygdala.
One way to get over a fear is called, "Exposure
Therapy," where psychotherapists use relaxation
techniques combined with desensitization to
help people curb and control their fears.
It's a tricky business, specialists have to
balance the exposure with the relaxation techniques,
using classical conditioning to retrain the
patient's limbic system.
Sort of like Pavlov training dogs to salivate
when they hear a bell, exposure therapy retrains
the amygdala so fear responses are desensitized.
They don't want to overwhelm the amygdala,
or they'll risk re-traumatizing the person,
so exposure therapy can take a while.
Instead, specialists will work to explore
the fear and desensitize one little bit at
a time.
So, if someone suffers from panic attacks,
psychologists might ask a patient run to get
their heart rate up, so they don't fear the
pounding in their chest.
It's pretty intense stuff!
Of course, fear of spiders, heights, and like…
sitting down (kathisophobia) are all pretty
easy to practice with exposure therapy.
Over time, when paired with relaxation training,
your amygdala will tone down the panic, and
patients are able to actually overcome the
fear!
For things where the patient CAN'T go back,
like abuse or military PTSD, psychotherapists
are turning to technology.
Virtual Reality Exposure, can put people in
controlled situations that help desensitize
bits of a bad experience in a safe environment.
Rather than putting someone who is afraid
of flying on an airplane, they could be put
in a VR headset!
The University of Southern California has
been using VR exposure therapy since 2005
to work with veterans of Iraq and Afghanistan.
Using a VR headset and an XBox game, military
personnel can experience virtual reality,
3D audio, vibrations and even smells -- helping
to selectively expose parts and desensitize
PTSD sufferers!
Technology to the rescue!
According to an NIH study in Journal of Clinical
Psychology, even after six sessions, patients
reported decreased feelings of psychological
distress and PTSD symptoms!
In another study in the Journal of Trauma
and Stress, VR therapy significantly reduced
symptoms in 62 percent of patients.
The limbic system evolved in a time when we
could be killed at any moment, and the fear
response was a way to keep us safe and alive.
Today, it would make sense to be able to shut
off this fear-based, ancient brain, but we're
not there yet.
Instead, we have to learn to overcome our
fears and live courageously.
Luckily, science is working on it!
You know who’s good at overcoming fear?
The brave men and women in the United States
Air Force!
Whether it’s overcoming poverty to become
a nurse and officer or becoming the first
female Thunderbird pilot, these Airmen are
doing what others once thought was impossible.
So, a big shout out to the U.S. Air Force
for making this episode possible!
What are you afraid of?